musik seit tausenden jahren bewegt sie
uns menschen aber trotz unserer
fortschritte in der wissenschaft können
wir uns immer noch nicht erklären warum
eine handvoll schwingungen in der luft
derart intensive gefühle in uns auslösen
kann vielleicht bietet musik sicherheit
auf der einen seite durch wiederholende
melodien und rhythmen aber genau die
richtige menge abenteuer abwechslung und
unsicherheit durch kleine variationen
und überraschungen
vielleicht bricht sie die harmonien uns
an die wir erfahren wenn wir mit einem
bein in der sicherheit und mit dem
anderen in der unsicherheit stehen genau
auf der grenze zwischen chaos und
ordnung
vielleicht aber auch nicht auf jeden
fall werde ich in dieser woche erstmal
die basics der musikproduktion lehrern
in erfahrung bringen wie man aus einem
computer töne raus quetscht die tausende
menschen zum feiern bringen und meinen
eigenen song produzieren und
anschließend versuchen ihnen auf spotify
aufzuladen
dieses video wird unterstützt von blink
ist und da ich keinen plan von musik
habe ich mir mache ist angeschrieben
geschnappt der zusammen mit vincent li
unter dem namen neues kriegs
professionell in clubs auf legt eine
woche wird zu der zeit ja ja ist es
überhaupt realistisch ja doch was er
ausgesucht fl studio ja was willst du
machen so musikrichtungen wie sie so
sehr wie twitter david guetta wird zu
machen ob ich okay also was hier schon
ein paar sachen entdeckt hier zum
beispiel kriegs überhaupt das ist den
keks gehen müssen die kicker haben dann
hast du ganz frischen keksen direkt
jüngsten saftiger klingen genau das
kommt über dem klub und jetzt waren noch
eines mehr ist also die basics von dem
bieten wir diesen
das mache dass wir jetzt einfach so ganz
normal wieder das gleichzeitig ganze
meine haus bietet jetzt fängt nämlich
das spaß an kann sich jappy lautstärke
regeln und vor allem kannst du dir doch
auch ganz viele effekte und wenn ihr
jetzt das hast du schon mal mehr drin
so sammelt jetzt kommen aber es
interessante instrumente ach so jetzt
geht das kilo
jetzt gibt er sich los
alter kollege das ist geil jetzt jetzt
könnte so eine richtig elektronisch wie
hast du das jetzt hingekriegt das so
heftig links erstmalig hochgeputscht
aschendorf iq und dadurch irgendwie
aufschreiben alte also für mich dass ich
das schon nach dem fertigen song mal
[Gelächter]
dicker das ist dann nicht einfach zumal
gesänge einfach keine angst ich werde
meinem song nicht singen aber schon
krass war sie marius aus meinem schiefen
dikrech zu hängen gezaubert hat wie
lustig das ist dass man da was soll ich
machen soll jetzt waren wir noch schnell
crashkurs im mixed deine kick sollte
nicht über null gehen sollte irgendwas
über null gehen nein und dann als erstes
als nächstes den bass immer von den
tiefen frequenzen und hört und bei den
tiefen frequenzen brauchen mehr
lautstärke wunder dass man die hört
schon krass
[Musik]
wenn ich hätte also finde ich die grafik
kurzen zahl das ist nicht der beste
track geworden aber so als tutorials
also wenn ihr was paid clicks halb so
geil dass wenn ich schon krass ja das
ist okay als allererstes weil ich mir
jetzt mal in liedern dass ich cool finde
und versuchte damals erst mal die drums
ungefährt zu verstehen und dann sowas
ähnliches zu machen da da ist er mache
jetzt meine melodie kommt
zudem brauche ich aber jemand auf dem
klavier das sieht so aus ob knie knacken
wir merken
dinge ich mache musik
[Musik]
aber es ist echt schwer sich eine
melodie einfallen zu lassen probiert das
mal überlegt euch jetzt einfach mal eine
melodie für einen hit song ja genau ist
schwierig da mehr aus dem kopf keine
melodie einfallen will setze ich mich
seit zwei jahren zum ersten mal an die
gitarre und versuche so durch
rumprobieren ideen zu finden aber auch
das funktioniert leider nicht
das wird nix ich habe amerika tiefe
blockade der ja ich mache das war pause
musiker kann man sich auch mal gönnen
oder gleich keinen plan hat von musik
wäre ich jetzt einfach mit
vorgefertigten kurz der kunde melodie
basteln
okay ich habe jetzt die ausgesuchte ich
will da ich kein plan dazu ich mir jetzt
einfach hier die raus hier zum beispiel
das abs kader nach
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe herausgefunden dass es bis zu
fünf tage dauert um den sommersport
hochzuladen
das heißt ich habe eine woche zeit
sondern zwei tage nichts co
[Musik]
okay das habe ich jetzt noch 212 die
melodie
wenn ich für ein anfang ganz cool
[Musik]
mein kopf ist so much
das hätte ich dir ja nie so richtig
krachen so eine hecke film eine freude
[Musik]
okay es ist schon mega spät was ich mir
da wieder angetan habe ich finds grad
echt also haben dieses ach ich finds ich
finde ich finds teilweise kulow kam
herein
[Musik]
ja also ich finde es okay ich pack das
ganze jetzt einmal marius und schauen
mal was er dazu zu sagen hat
es ist so unangenehm dass setzen den
menschen zu zeigen brinkmann ist klingt
der hack war cool das war ja ist nicht
einfach es ist nicht einfach
also die kurzen coolpix ich ein bisschen
krass drauf ich nehme mir marius kritik
zu herzen und setzte sie in die tat um
die snare wird leiser gemacht auf diesen
sound kommt mir halt ich ziehe mir eine
simple baseline aus dem ärmel
überlagere die hauptmelodie mit
verschiedenen instrumenten
[Musik]
ich habe mich kreativ ausflüge
verschiedene effekte hinzu und passe
stunden lang die lautstärke der
einzelnen spuren an
[Musik]
durch das feedback klingt unser bild
schon viel stimmiger und montag bzw
dienstag 41 ist es soweit doch wie lebt
man einen song überhaupt auf spotify
hoch kann das jeder nein tatsächlich
nicht aber irgendwie auch schon es geht
zwar nicht einfach so wie bei youtube
aber mit einem dienst der ungefähr 20
euro pro jahr kostet kann ich meinen
song also auf spotify aber auch auf alle
anderen plattformen wie zum beispiel
apple music itunes und amazon hochladen
mein künstlername ist natürlich toll und
der release date ist samstag 11 uhr als
artwork nehme ich ganz einfach mal den
kanal banner und ich finde auch dass der
zum song ziemlich gut passt die
schwierigste entscheidung war wohl der
name und ich entscheide mich für die
projekt heißt es daumen drücken dass der
song angenommen und von spotify
akzeptiert wird dass mein song wie
findest du also ohne mein erstes war
wesentlich wesentlich beschützen ich
habe es jetzt einfach mal gefragt ich
habe den song geschickt werden
das ist absolut stark geworden dafür
dass du das vorher nie gemacht hast ich
hoffe dass das video von dir den gepäck
haben wird dass leute sich denken oh
krass das kann man an zwei tagen machen
vielleicht fange ich auch an zu
produzieren der sollte jetzt online sein
die
es ist ein brauch spotify rad befahren
strangers gefühl auf spotify einen song
zu haben ich habe ja auch videos auf
youtube aber irgendwie spotify sollen
mitsingen wie so oft es jedoch keine
ahnung
es war auf jeden fall jetzt eine krasse
woche ich hatte ja für den song nur drei
tage zeit hat übel bock gemacht es ist
natürlich jetzt kein krasses sagen ich
habe jetzt auch nicht innerhalb von ein
paar tagen gelernt mega heftige musik zu
machen und um richtig gute musik zu
machen dauert natürlich monate oder eher
gesagt jahres alle 14 k s wie viel spaß
sich damit schon innerhalb von drei
tagen gehabt hat und jetzt einmal einen
eigenen zeugenaussagen ist schon jetzt
schon ist schon cool
böse zungen würden wir haben das was ich
in diesem video produziert habe wäre er
aber wusstet ihr dass absolute stille
für uns sogar ungesund ist das buch nur
im weltall ist es wirklich still klärt
auf warum nicht gleich lärm ist und wie
man ihn bekämpfe zwei blinkt ist dem
sponsor des heutigen videos gibt es
unzählige lehrreichen bücher dieser art
wie man in jeder alltagssituation
nebenbei hören kann um seine zeit
perfekt zu nutzen
linke ist berühmt für die geniale
zusammenfassung von büchern mit der man
den kern eines buches in nur 15 minuten
lesen oder anhören kann oder mit anhören
in doppelter geschwindigkeit sogar in 75
minuten wenn euch die zusammenfassung
gepackt hat könnt ihr jetzt jederzeit
mit hörbüchern in voller länge das
gesamte buch aufsaugen es gibt unzählige
bücher mit unschätzbar wertvollen wissen
zu den themen geld psychologie
unternehmertum produktivität
wissenschaft und viele mehr auf deutsch
und auf englisch und jeden monat
gesellen sie circa 40 titel in 25
kategorien hinzu saugt jetzt kostenlos
so viel wissen auch wie ihr könnt auf
link fsd.de tommy und das noch bevor
irgend ein abo abschließt meinen
zuschauer erhalten exklusiv 20 prozent
rabatt auf das jahres-abo blinkt es
premium link fsd.de story im nächsten
video versuche ich innerhalb von sieben
tagen eine app zu entwickeln und diese
dann zu promoten und damit möglichst
viel geld zu verdienen wenn er jetzt
schon angegeben wo es auf youtube kommt
abonniert mich gerne auf instagram und
abonniert diesen kanal und dann sehen
wir uns beim nächsten mal wieder macht's
gut
[Musik]